nouveau rassemblement solidarité avec le
peuple palestinien journée d'action
nationale notamment à paris où nous
retrouvons tout de suite notre reporter
jonathan madame bonjour à jonathan alors
comment je passe ce rassemblement
statique
et bien plusieurs centaines de personnes
sont toujours présentes ici place de la
république pour rendre hommage selon
leurs termes aux martyrs de la
résistance palestinienne une place de la
république très fortement sécurisée par
les forces de l'ordre des canons à eau
ont été déployés des barrières
anti-émeute des gendarmes mobiles
et justement pour parler de
l'organisation assez particulière de
cette manifestation
je suis avec walid à talas qui est porte
parole de l'association des palestiniens
d'île de france
ça a été compliqué d'organiser cette
manifestation et même une précédente
manifestation le 15 mai avait été
interdite et pour celle ci aussi vous
avez eu des problèmes de ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi c'est si
compliqué en ce moment en france
d'organiser des manifestations de
soutien au peuple palestinien va écouter
ça a été clairement dit par le président
de la république et le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur darmana le
président de la république emmanuel
macron a soutenu inconditionnellement
l'état d'israël contre ce qu'il a appelé
les organisations terroristes
palestiniennes
et ça c'est c'est inadmissible c'est un
parti pris
donc pour un état colonial et
et c'est eux qui importe le conflit en
france en prenant position pour un état
colonial qui tous les jours
commet des crimes de guerre dans les
territoires occupés bon là en
l'occurrence il ya eu les bombardements
sur gaza il ya eu plus de plus de 200
morts et mais c'est tous les jours que
les crimes se se commettent
donc voilà pourquoi la solidarité a du
mal à se faire entendre à paris en
france
mais malgré tout on y est arrivé et
notre association qui avait fait la
déclaration pour la manifestation du 15
mai on a eu l'arrêté d'interdiction au
dernier moment sans possibilité de se
rassembler c'était clair et net la
préfecture de police a dit il faut
dispersé toute tentative de
rassemblement et de manifestation
aujourd'hui pour cette manifestation on
avait déclaré le même parcours
c'est à dire barbès bah si mais il y a
eu un arrêté encore d'interdiction mais
en nous disant vous pouvez vous vous
réunira république
voilà donc ça a été un petit succès bon
parce qu'il ne ne veulent pas quand même
revoir les mêmes images de de troubles
qui a eu le samedi 15 et finalement ils
ont dit oui il y à un risque de trouble
à l'ordre public alors que c'est eux qui
ont poussé alors au désordre public
pascoe schreyer aujourd'hui les deux
rassemblements prouve que les gens y
viennent ils sont pacifiques vous
m'expliquez tout à vous êtes vous-même
palestiniens en 1968 après la la guerre
de 67 vous avez dû fuir les territoires
occupés par israël
c'est important pour vous ici de faire à
votre à votre niveau acte de résistance
pour la cause palestienne oui bien sûr
c'est d'abord dire que le peuple
palestinien il est uni qu'il soit à
l'intérieur à l'extérieur à l'intérieur
ils subissent directement l'occupation
et à l'extérieur c'est les palestiniens
qui sont réfugiés qui sont en exil qui
sont interdits de retour sur leurs
terres
il faut savoir que sur 13 millions de
palestiniens
il y à 7 millions c'est à dire la
majorité qui sont réfugiés voilà donc
nous sommes la majorité exilés interdit
de retour et est donc on prend la parole
et on est solidaire de nos frères bien
sûr de la résistance palestinienne de la
lutte de libération
un mot sur le cessez le feu qui a été
signé entre le hamas et israël le 21 mai
il ya deux jours sous l'égide de
l'egypte
comment vous vous recevez cette nouvelle
du cessez-le-feu ce que pour vous c'est
une bonne nouvelle c'est un espoir de
paix dans ce conflit qui dure depuis
plus de 70 ans aujourd'hui
bano d'abord c'est une bonne nouvelle
d'abord pour les palestiniens qui ont
subi les bombardements pendant pendant
dix jours
ma famille qui est là-bas à gaza une
partie il est demandé que la la
puissance utilisés pour bombarder
c'est pour détruire ces des bombes de
plus d'une tonne c'est pour détruire des
immeubles entiers c'est pour détruire
des quartiers entiers ils ont détruit
les routes qui pour empêcher les gens de
circuler les ambulances de circuler les
secours de circuler en général voilà
c'est ça la réalité de donc bien sûr
pour pour le pour les civils
palestiniens
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais le
problème c'est que et ce n'est pas
cesser le feu pour le l'occupation qui
continue le la colonisation qui
continuent quotidiennement le blocus de
gaza qui continue c'est ça le problème
ce qui a eu
les américains les français et l'europe
et ils sont intervenus pour faire le
cessez le feu
c'est parce que l'image de 2,2 du
massacre en direct ça devenait
insoutenable donc il fallait quelque
part trouvé un cessez-le-feu mais mais
en fait rien n'est réglé puisque encore
ce matin les groupes de colons à
jérusalem ils sont allés avec la
protection de l'armée israélienne la
police
ils sont allés sur l'esplanade des
mosquées donc c'est encore et encore et
encore tous les jours la provocation
tous les jours les colons israéliens ils
occupent des maisons palestiniennes à
jérusalem
tous les jours il y a des pas les siens
qui sont tués sur les tchèques punk les
barrages israéliens en cisjordanie
voilà c'est ça la réalité du peuple
palestinien et ça ils ont une personne
n'en parle
et il n'y a aucune sanction contre
l'état d'israël
donc ce qui va se passer c'est ce qui
s'est déjà passé à gaza c'est là la
guerre qui a eu lieu en 2008 2009 en
2012 en 2014
aujourd'hui en 2021 et ça va recommencer
parce que les colons israéliens
il continue tous les jours a occupé et à
apprendre des maisons des palestiniens
voilà c'est ça qu'il faut dire et on
veut dire aux gens de rester mobilisés
pour pouvoir continuer la solidarité je
remercie monsieur atallah pour avoir
répondu
nos questions donc deux jours après la
signature de ce cessez-le-feu ou le
voyez les gens accueillent cette
nouvelle de façon mitigée car ce cette
trêve
certains craignent qu'elle soit malgré
tout fragile
merci je m'attends pour toutes ces
précisions